so when you've identified a problem
point in your app how do you go about
figuring about what the best solution is
for that so the first thing to realize
is that to some extent honestly there is
no best solution there are lots of best
solutions and your job is just to find
one the fastest you possibly can so the
best way to do that is actually through
quantity rather than quality don't
necessarily focus on finding the best
solution just come up with the first
thing that you think might be better and
then come up with the next ten things
that you think might be better and then
make prototypes of all of those again
we're going for fast and cheap so that
this is a really quick process make 10
prototypes test them all and see which
is better okay then do that three more
times or four more times or five more
times and eventually you'll start to
settle in and really understand what
people care about and what's the best
and what really is valuable to them
right